Matthew
24:14 and this Gospel of the Kingdom
will be preached throughout the whole
world as a testimony to All Nations and
then the end will come all right so
notice the condition the end of this age
the end of Jerusalem the end of Israel
as God's covenant people the end of the
temple being where God dwells and meets
with his people the end of the Testament
age and period cannot come until the
gospels preach throughout the whole
world now let me show you how marvelous
the Bible is and amazing and why not
anyone should be picking up and teaching
God's word the Bible in the wrong hands
like this guy is dangerous may God save
his word from Bible perverts who think
they know but they don't and may God
destroy our pride not to be like that
okay what does world mean and here's my
question if you're listening you serious
students of the Bible if you're
listening did the gospel spread
throughout the world before 70 AD
because if I'm right he's telling about
the end of Jerusalem then the gospel
must have been preached throughout the
world before God destroyed Jerusalem in
70 AD did the gospel spread over the
world before 70 AD yes here you go
Romans 1 verse
8 listen
your Bible says yes that condition was
meant listen in Jesus name be focused
and I will then open up Q&A Romans 1
ver8 first I thank my God through Jesus
Christ for all of you because your faith
is proclaimed in all the world so when
Paul is writing to the Romans in the
60s he's saying already Christians have
spread all over the world and Christians
throughout the world have heard about
your faith
wow really okay now watch and then want
to open up the
Q&A Colossians 1
5-6 Colossians 1 5-6 watch
here Colossians one that's why the
Muslim got stumped because he thought I
don't know this argument he got stumped
he got humiliated that's why he ran
because he couldn't then defend Muhammad
saying Jesus would descend in the
lifetime his companions a false prophet
see because Muhammad is a false prophet
Colossians 1 5-6 watch because of the
Hope laid up for you in heaven of this
you have heard before in the word of
Truth meaning the gospel you've heard it
the gospel which has come to you as
indeed in the whole world it is bearing
fruit and
growing so among yourselves from the day
you heard and understood the grace of
God in truth wait Paul says already in
the 50s and 60s when he's writing the
gospel has already borne fruit in the
whole world see
it Colossians 1
22-23 Colossians 1
22-23
ready Colossians 1
22-23 he has now Rec iled in his body of
Flesh by his death in order to present
you holy and blameless and IR
approachable before him provided notice
once saved always saved destroyed
provided that you continue the faith you
see it you will be preserved by God made
holy and blameless above reproach if you
remain faithful continue Faith stable
and steadfast I well what if you fall
away then you lose this hope it's right
there bye-bye one saved always saved
okay not shifting from the hope of the
Gospel which you heard which has been
preached to every creature under heaven
and of which I Paul became a minister
did you guys catch
that already before the
70 AD in the 50s 60s
the apostles are saying the gospel has
preached has been preached throughout
the world to every creature under Heaven
meaning that condition was fulfilled
because they were not defining the term
World from a 21 century understanding
and Jesus wasn't talking to you he's
talking to a first century audience and
he knew what he he meant by world the
world as they knew it this gospel must
spread throughout the world as you know
it and then Jerusalem will be
destroyed you get it well wait there's
more you with me so
far that condition has been fulfilled
right all right but here's one more
watch here let me give you one more in
fact even acts told you that on
Pentecost by the provision of God Jews
from All Nations under Heaven were there
and the 3,000 that got saved then they
spread all over the world and went back
to their countries and preached the
gospel so even during that period in the
30s the world had the gospel preached
I'll show it to you hold
on but let me go through this you see
why the Bible in the wrong hands is a
dangerous
weapon Romans 10113
to18 is it all making sense now
okay Earth I'm praise the Lord now
you're not stumped
anymore
see this answer your question all right
good sister okay everyone got
it everyone getting it because now watch
here Paul clearly says the gospel that
saves has been proclaimed throughout the
world throughout the world here Romans
to18 okay pay attention Skywalker Romans
10:1 13:18 it's about the gospel Paul
says have they all heard the gospel
already he goes yes their voice has gone
out throughout the world quoting Psalm
19:4 here it is Romans
101318 for everyone who calls upon the
name of the Lord will be saved that's
the gospel but then he ask a question
watch but how are men to call upon him
in whom they have not believed you can't
call on someone you don't know about and
you can't believe in someone you don't
know and how are they to believe in him
of whom they have never heard how am I
going to call on someone I don't know
never
heard and how are they going to hear
without a preacher see he's saying see
we need preachers or how are they going
to know about Jesus to believe in Jesus
to call on Jesus and how can men preach
unless they are sent now watch as it is
written
how beautiful are the feet of those who
preach good
news okay but they have not all heeded
the gospel for as Isaiah says Lord who
has believed what he has heard from us
see not everyone now watch so faith
comes from what is heard and what is
heard comes by the preaching of Christ
but now he answers the question but I
ask have they not
heard all right have they not heard
indeed they have for their voice has
gone out to all the Earth and their
words to the ends of the world end of
story and Paul wrote this in the 60s and
he's telling you already the gospel has
been preached to the ends of the
world that part of
Jesus's condition was already met and
shortly thereafter Jerusalem was
destroyed see
you see
it right there Romans
10:19 have they not heard indeed they
have for their voice those who preach
the word of Christ has gone out to all
the Earth and their words to the ends of
the
world so Matthew
24:14 that condition was already met